[Music]
[Music]
hallo YouTube chess Louis and my friends
this is guns in here welcome to my yet
another attacking chess series where as
per the requests from many viewers I'm
going to present one attacking chess
gambit against a foe
now this gambit is a perfectly suitable
for the short version of the chess games
such as blitz and rapid games however
with extensive preparation you can
definitely try in Fida games which can
utilize as a great shock weapon after E
for the setup I am going to recommend
this Philidor defense which arises after
the following model if I Knight to f3
and now black play this passive move d6
which at first sight doesn't even
looking like black is going for any sort
of attacking position now if you check
this position in online database you
will find out that d4 is by far the
highest Lee played move and that is
something we are going to look in depth
however stay tuned as by end of this
lecture I'm going to also show you how
you should play against the move Bishop
to c4 as it is very common at the
beginner level
okay so d4 very logical move white grab
the space in the center and open up the
to Bishop however black has the equally
nice and a tricky move namely Bishop to
g4 this is not a new MU guys this is an
old move and I still remember that it
was frequently played until Murphy came
and destroyed this line and after that
this line completely goes out of the
fashion let me just briefly point out
what is the problem after Bishop to g4
white can't continue 8d captures ePHI
and Murphy's opponent at this point
realize that
he cannot even Cree capture the pawn as
after Queen exchange
the resulting position is quite
favorable to the white camp so
accordingly he decided to first capture
this night and after Queen captures f3
now he regained the pawn back with D cap
to c5 so at first sight this position
looks innocent but after morph is
accurate sequence Bishop to c4
threatening a checkmate and after more
fees opponent bad move Knight to f6
Murphy shows the potential in this line
with Queen to b3 attacking to sports
within just seventh move of the game and
unfortunately black cannot defend both
of them so this is the game which more
or less refute the Bishop to g4 setup
however we are in the modern era and the
gambit I am about to show you can shock
a lot of your opponent as after the move
D kept his ePHI rather than capturing on
f3 my suggestion here is you continue
with Knight to d7 gamba ting yet another
pawn on d6 and if White has to keep his
advantage then he has to take the second
pawn for example if I'd continue here
with either the move Bishop to e2 or
Knight to c3 not taking the second pawn
then the simplest answer is you can grab
this pawn with D captures ePHI and not
only claim the fair share of the game
but as I have highlighted over here
black can now easily put up his Philidor
structure and this time around this
black Bishop has more good spaces to go
so all in all I think in such variations
black instantly equalized the game
so let's check out what happens when
white grab the second bone which is in
fact again the highest Lee played moon
and the response is very obvious yup we
are going to take with the bishop and to
be honest I like such a attacking
structures it is okay that black is a
pawn down but look at the piece
development black is having the three
minor pieces are already out and white
has the only developed piece night which
is pinned by our bishop the good thing
is there is no theory in these positions
and the most important factor you have
to remember is whichever side White King
goes let's say if he goes to the Kings
side then we are going to go on the
Queen side and that way we have a very
fun and enjoyable game as a black camp
now to illustrate the power of this
position I like to show you a model game
which will give you a clear path how you
can play as a black from this position
from here onwards game continue with
Bishop to e2 unpinning the knight and
ready to castle on the Kings side so as
a black you know now what to do
yup the very obvious move Queen to e7
all set to castle on the Queen side and
after White Castle black indeed castle
on the Queen side lining up this rook to
the White Queen now before we move on I
like to make this video very interactive
so at certain point of the game I will
ask you to pause this video and find the
best attacking move and let's see how
good attacking genius sitting inside you
of the first movement guys white
continue with s3 attacking ever bishop
and now ball is in your court
how are you going to respond to the
small concrete solutions if you find
this attacking move h5 not giving up the
ground and telling white you can't even
touch that bishop sweetie and I think we
all familiar about this patron right
if white take this bishop then after
edge captures g4 that knight cannot move
in the view of Bishop to edge to check
and if white insists to save the piece
with Knight to g5 then after Bishop
twedge to check came to h1 Bishop to f4
discovered chat to the King King to g1
and now not only black get the piece
back in a style but the open edge file
can be the disaster ever new for the
white camp
software H fire rightly so white didn't
capture the bishop and he continued it
Knight to c3 okay after that black
continued it very obvious blonde first
he captured on f3 and after Bishop
captures f3 now comes the second star mu
are you ready yup it's g5 and position
looks so scary for the white camp look
at the Queen side
he still hasn't developed and this pawn
hasn't moved where black is about to
touch on the Kings side as a black you
can't ask more than this position looks
already decisive for the white camp in
the game
white continue with g3 but I like to
mention important point here that taking
on edge fire is not a remedy for the
white cam as this open edge file
provides great attacking stuff for the
black camp after Bishop to h5 a sample
line can goes like this f5 so blacks
idea is very potent he wants to stop
this check so let's say if white
foolishly take on a fire then after
Knight d2 F 6 we are threatening two
things number one capturing the bishop
and the second and the most obvious
potent threat is Bishop to h2 check and
nabbing the White Queen so obviously why
shouldn't capture on f5 and accordingly
the base sequence goes as follows
Bishop to g6 attacking on fi black
should now play the move f4 and after
Bishop to a5 just unpin this Knight
immediately with King to be it yes
white can harass you for a time being
let's say Knight to d5 but after Queen
to g7 as you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows very simple
plan for the black camp is to play
Knight to e5 Knight 2 at 6:00 and then
either capture on a fire or play with g4
in any circumstances it is only black
who is having all the fun in this line
so let's check out what is going on
after the move g3 which was played in
the game
well black doesn't need any second
invitation he crashed through with g4
and after the obvious response s
captures g4
here comes a third nice move of the game
h4 ripping apart the White King side
when you pressurize your opponent like
this even strong players do make errors
and no wonder
white committed his first mistake of the
game playing the moon King to g2 after
that black toss become more easy he
first opened up the H file with H
captures g3 and when white recaptured
the pawn black plays the winning move of
the game which you need to find out
second time guys I want you to stop this
video and find out our decisive move are
you ready
did you find this varying blow yup
is what a move this rook sacrifice is
such a potent that white can't even
touch it as after Queen to h4 check
white King is going to be checkmated so
the only logical response here is to go
to the Jeevan square but even after this
Bishop captures g3 and Queen to h4 is
coming next and no matter however why
triggers
he get a completely losing position at
just 14th move of the game for example
Bishop to e3 we can go ahead with Queen
to h4 and now how you going to stop
checkmate in four moves the answer is
you can't
now before we leave I like to mention
what you should do against the move
Bishop to c4 which is the second most
popular choice by wide and against this
our setup will remain same yup we are
going to play Bishop to g4 and no matter
how well white plays we are getting our
typical fielder structure with no
problem at all
for example if h3 then Bishop to h5 and
black will keep his bishop pair and move
such as d3 doesn't create any problem as
after Knight to f6 as you can see I have
highlighted by the arrows the official
Philidor structure which is rock-solid
so no problem at all and finally if the
operand continue with d4 at this point
then again if you recall of a gambit
section yup the obvious move Knight to
d7 and black is reasonably plays the
point is if white continue with either
the move Knight to c3 or c3 then we can
continue with Knight G to f6 again
getting of a typical field of structure
and if white continue with D captures
ePHI then this is even versed as after
Knight captures ePHI not only this
Knight is attacking the bishop
but as this Knight is attacked twice
white has to waste one move with Bishop
to e2 and that way
black gained a very important temple
so more or less this is how you should
respond against the moo3 Bishop to c4
that's it guys I hope you enjoy and
learn this wonderful attacking gambit
against the movie for remember when you
opponent played the move he kept his 'if
I give him this rude shock with Knight
to d7 and after pawn takes d6 and the
move Bishop captures d6 the fun begins
when opposite side castle happened where
black laying development can be a
decisive factor thank you for watching
this video feel free to like subscribe
and comment and I'll meet you in my next
episode very soon bye and take care